dan wrote in saying hey what's the
craziest diet you guys have ever heard
of have you tried crazy or odd diets for
me the craziest diets are the ones that
are the the consumption of very few
foods so like for example fruitarianism
where you basically eat just fruits and
nuts and and essentially no grains no
meat no dairy bla bla bla bla bla
the highly limited number of foods
you're allowed to eat to me seemed like
the craziest diets particularly because
it doesn't seem like those are hugely
healthy diets both emotionally and
physically and I've never tried any of
those now yeah the fruitarian one is
kind of crazy I'm sure you can get all
the nutrients and everything that you
may need amino acids micronutrients from
a fruit based diet that you would have
to eat so much food the I mean the
weight of the amount of food because
most of the fruit is just water yes
indeed and so eight to get 2000 3000
calories a day I mean that's a hard task
most people don't need 3000 calories a
day I mean I don't know what you're
doing after the show but Pat's talk to
me a little bit about his gym routines
but I didn't I didn't realize we were at
3,000 calories a day yeah I I have not
really tried any diet I've adjusted my
diet over time so I eat less meat for
sure I stopped eating pork several years
ago I eat very little red meat and yeah
so I think I've adjusted my diet but I
don't know that I've tried a crazy or
odd diet I do know someone who had was
for a while on a diet where there's only
like I think 25 items you can eat now
I'm not talking about 25 dishes I'm
talking about 25 ingredients it was
insane I mean this person basically
couldn't go out anywhere obviously and I
think it lasted like three months and
that's the problem with a lot of these
debt diets that if it's no matter what
happens when you're on the diet if you
can't stay on it because it's so
impractical and unsustainable it's not
really a good diet yeah it's a really
hard thing to go out in public and eat
the same way as if you're buying
groceries for yourself yeah have you
noticed the the Soylent craze that is
taking over toyline is this meal
replacing GLE ingredient you would need
every Etrian in the in the right amount
of ratios and I think if you eat if you
drink like five of these
per day you got the right 2000 calories
you need so it's liquid it's a liquid
yeah I guess it tastes like it kind of
tastes like milk that's been sitting out
for a little while yeah when you say you
guess
haven't you tried this stuff yeah you're
not really guessing you're just telling
us this is what it tastes this is my an
assessment of what the taste is yeah
it's like milk having been out for a
little while or mixed with cereal yeah
and you drink it after and is it is it
vegan I'm guessing because it is yeah
what what are what are the ingredients
that make it up I would have to I mean
it's like soy it's made in the lab it
means completely processed yeah
everything I mean if you have five of
these bottles a day that's your 2000
calorie taken me meaning that 20% of
your daily need for vitamin C vitamin a
protein whatever it is is in each of
those individual bottle yeah yeah I
don't know it's a very utilitarian
approach to nutrition isn't it I guess
so I mean you don't have to worry about
cooking and cleaning as much yeah yeah
I'm not feeling drawn to it but yeah I
have been reading about the whole
Soylent craze and I believe there's a
science fiction movie from decades ago
that originally had sort of like an
equivalent I think it might have even
been called Soylent that's where the
name comes from and the toilet was
people in the end I'm surprised that
you're not dumb ho about this given my
explanation of the taste no it doesn't
sound particularly good I'm also not
into I mean I just think in general if
you think back to the hunter-gatherer
roots of humans that involves eating a
pretty significant diversity of food it
doesn't seem natural to me just to be
eating or drinking only one thing I
guess I mean if you look at
hunter-gatherer days though they were
looking for very dense foods and you
know high caloric intake all at once so
that could supply you for days on end
right yeah but they were eating
everything from nuts to you know tree
berries to the every once in a while you
might be able to kill an animal it's all
in Soylent yeah right but it's the same
thing every single day what do you have
if you want to have a late-night snack
just like a little bit of Soylent you
have one bottle of so yeah okay I'm not
looking to try that soon if you're
looking to try it let me know we've got
a great bonus show for you today david
pakman.com slash membership the coupon
code continues in the era of President
Donald Orange the coupon code is I voted